hola que tal soy john black y escucha
esta fernanda rocha y la importancia de
esta humanidad aumentada
yo también coincido con eso y creo que
la humanidad va a experimentar un
periodo de transformación total mira te
voy a platicar de tres ideas uno de la
humanidad interplanetaria dos de la
humanidad extendida y la tercera
humanidad artificial ok vamos a
explorando las primeras primer tema la
inteligencia artificial es inevitable se
va a convertir en una herramienta más
eficiente que nosotros se buscaba que la
singularidad llegara para después del
2030 pero es probablemente que en esta
década de los veintes lleguemos al final
de la década con una singularidad la
inteligencia artificial se va a
convertir en una herramienta poderosa de
hecho ya lo estamos viendo ahora hemos
visto cómo inauguramos esta década de
los 20 20 con estos robots danzantes o
recientemente con el gran potencial que
hemos visto de sincronización y
ejecución de tareas y está bien vernos
de una manera como herramientas pero
también hay quien está pensándolo para
otro tipo de actividades que no
necesariamente
presentan lo mejor de la ética humana
sin embargo está pasando no podemos
evitarlo está ahí podemos hablar de él
entender hacia dónde se dirige y eso nos
daría una ventaja pero quiero que veas
esta imagen esta imagen representa mucho
porque cuando la veía me preguntaba cómo
podría ser la infancia de los niños del
futuro
ya la viste otro tipo de pregunta que
venía a mi cabeza es qué tipo de nuevas
relaciones se van a crear entre ambos
otra pregunta es qué tipo de nuevas
compañías veremos de esa relación porque
cada relación nueva significa una
oportunidad también comercial y sobre
todo la más importante estamos listos tú
y yo para esa transformación
mira esto ya no es un tema de futuro ya
está pasando ahora basta con ver algunos
de tus dispositivos de inteligencia
artificial que ya están en tu casa tu
reloj tu dispositivo de guía o tu
teléfono móvil ya cuentan con una de
estas características es más hay una
compañía que se llama en boa diet que ha
creado este robot llamado mochi el cual
ya es un acompañante este es un robot
que ya acompaña a los niños en su día a
día en su aprendizaje diario en su
descubrimiento del mundo por lo tanto
esto dejó de ser un tema de futuro y
está pasando nos
en esta línea del tiempo la inteligencia
artificial como te decía va a llenarlo
todo inclusive hay países en este
momento que están jugando con ella para
crear todo un sistema económico
alrededor de la inteligencia artificial
no solo visto como una herramienta sino
también ahora la inteligencia artificial
puede tener algoritmos de escaneo
y análisis de rostros entender quién
eres y asignarle una calificación de
cómo te comportas dentro de ese sistema
si pagas tus impuestos si eres un buen
ciudadano si eres una persona ejemplar
en tu trabajo todo esto se va acumulando
en un nuevo ranking de sistema social
china viene trabajando con esto más de
media década y claro distintos países en
distintas partes del mundo están
preguntándose en este momento cómo
incluimos esto en la administración
pública y sabes qué va a suceder los
países del mundo van a buscar
perfeccionar esto porque la tecnología
está ahí para servirnos
lo que va a ocurrir es que se va a crear
una economía de plataforma nosotros le
decimos platform economy y va a estar
rodeada de cinco círculos el primero el
comercio electrónico el segundo la
economía o la economía de conciertos el
tercero la economía de creador o curator
economy el cuarto la economía de la
pasión o passion economy y una quinta
que me parece una brutalidad brutalidad
en el concepto el metaverso economía la
economía de los metaversos estas cinco
cualidades están definiendo cómo se va a
comportar la economía en plataforma e
inteligencia artificial por lo tanto
esto va a abrir nuevos modelos de
negocio ya ser modelos figuras como
quieran llamarlo antes teníamos muy
claros qué significaba el business to
consumer consumer t consumer consumer to
business business to business todas
estas modalidades hoy han quedado
rebasadas y ya no se trata de human to
human como en algún momento a inicios de
los 2000 es comenzábamos a platicar todo
quienes estábamos metidos en el mundo de
la economía digital ahora es algo mucho
más allá imaginé texto human machine
human y esto es algo que tú ya vives
todos los días en el momento que pides
un über eres un humano que ya no está
hablando con una operadora está hablando
con una inteligencia artificial un
algoritmo que conecta quién eres y el
valor que tienes en la red con la
calidad de personas disponibles cercanas
para que puedan llevarte en el über esto
lo hace un algoritmo lo hace una
inteligencia artificial que califica el
conductor se califica a ti y te brinda
un servicio de conexión y luego un
humano que es el conductor llega en su
coche por ti esta es una relación human
machine
human imagínate una relación human
machine machine y esto ya lo vemos
prácticamente todas las redes sociales
human über tú quieres moverte algún
lugar abres tu app y en ese aumento es
machine la machine y todo el algoritmo
que está dentro de la máquina te dan la
mejor recomendación y luego nuevamente
sigue siendo machine porque ahora qué
crees ya no hay un conductor humano
ahora el conductor es una inteligencia
artificial you man machine machine te
imaginas todas las nuevas
configuraciones de modelos de negocio
que vamos a estar viendo producto de
esta intersección
los humanos ante este mundo alto de
competencia mucha competencia contra los
algoritmos es un hecho que para finales
de esta década
uno de cada tres empleados que conoces
va a ser ocupado por una inteligencia
artificial esto te va a cuestionar
durísimo porque todos los humanos vamos
a querer actualizarnos para no ser
obsoletos hay varias compañías que en el
presente están trabajando en esto en
este proyecto de neural ink está
tratando de entender cómo procesamos la
información hacia donde se podrían mover
neural link a este tipo de cosas como
ergo night que son estas cascos
cerebrales que te ayuden a tener mejor
eficiencia en la ejecución desde dormir
mejor hasta pensar mejor o ejecutar
ciertas acciones de nuestro día a día de
una manera más competente
estas nuevas coronas tecnológicas van a
estimular tu cerebro van a permitir que
tu capacidad neuronal pueda amplificarse
con un solo objetivo
amplificar la capacidad humana frente a
un mundo de alta volatilidad de alta
competencia y de altísima rudeza
intelectual y de procesamiento ya vemos
varios humanos que están ahí neil
harbisson es uno de estas personas que
ya lograron amplificar su capacidad de
ver y alrededor del mundo ocurren varios
experimentos científicos como el de
alexis churkin que está trabajando sobre
temas neuronales o estos auriculares que
te permiten amplificar la capacidad de
sonido que tenemos hoy con nuestros
oídos o que te di que me dices de los
awards que se han creado prótesis para
poder volver a recuperar brazos perdidos
o mejorar el brazo que ya tenemos estos
son cuestionamientos que vamos a
enfrentar como humanidad podemos
hacernos mejores en nuestra capacidad
física es decir en nuestro hardware a
través de estos implantes
exoesqueletos lentes artificiales ojos
artificiales procesamiento cerebral
esta es una cualidad que vamos a ver en
esta se va a abrir un gran mercado de
amplificación de cualidades físicas
humanas
y no solamente las cualidades físicas
ahora también las cualidades virtuales
estoy hablando de estos mundos híbridos
en donde vamos a vivir en una
representación digital o un avatar que
va a estar conviviendo en escenarios
digitales o metaversos o que me dices de
estos avatares que son nosotros mismos
pero son una réplica de nosotros que van
a vivir en mercados digitales tú ya lo
habías visto cuando jugabas videojuegos
estabas operando a otro ser digital que
es una extensión tuya en ese mundo
digital pues ahora vamos a ver mundos en
3-d en donde tú vas a tener un
representante digital dentro de ese
mundo y adentro de ese mundo va a haber
economía facebook bien apostando muy
fuerte sobre estos conceptos y no
solamente esto todas las compañías
tecnológicas tienen claro sobre todo la
de las redes sociales que dejaron de ser
redes sociales de interconexión en
humanos y ahora son redes sociales que
van a conectar humanos en un mundo
digital
ese mundo del mundo digital van a ser
metaversos donde vas a poder crear
economías vas a poder jugar nuevos
ecosistemas vas a poder vivir vidas
digitales
último tema la humanidad va a llegar a
marte si en verdad en esta década a ti
ya mí nos va a tocar ver cómo la
humanidad trasciende a esos lugares y va
a nacer el primer humano en marte
habíamos tenido miedo en el pasado de
que los marcianos nos iban a invadir y
que los marcianos lucían como estos
seres verdes siempre fuimos los humanos
vamos a hacer los humanos los primeros
marcianos qué va a pasar con ese ser
humano va a evolucionar
imagínate en la gravedad su cuerpo es
distinto la gravedad del peso el sistema
óseo la capacidad que tiene físicamente
hablando ese ser humano va a ser
distinto a nosotros vamos a ver entonces
la primera raza interplanetaria y eso va
a ser un nuevo concepto nos va a traer
nuevas preguntas y nosotros vamos a
estar ahí
de hecho la tecnología crisis pero qué
es esta tecnología que permite hoy dar
saltos evolutivos en la genética
intervenir como si fueran pedazos de
programación
como nosotros estamos diseñado en
términos genéticos va a mejorar va a
resolver problemas va a resolver temas
de salud como bill 19 hubiera sido algo
tan fácil de manipular si crisis pero ya
estuviera en activo editando eso vamos a
jugar a ser dioses con la capacidad de
creación genética esos son los temas
importantes la humanidad va a atravesar
todas estas cosas en esta década y en la
que sigue y eso va a transformar
brutalmente la concepción del humano
pero hay una y es la última que voy a
mencionar que va a tocarlo todo y es el
medio ambiente tú y yo hemos vivido en
negocios que solamente han tenido un
objetivo crear recursos somos profits
centristas amantes del dinero creadores
del valor de la rapidez de la explosión
masiva del consumo pero al mismo tiempo
no nos preguntamos durante cuánto tiempo
podíamos sostener este modelo y nos va a
tocar a nuestra generación lidiar con el
impacto
el más grande de la historia
vamos a tener que frenar rediseñar
modelos entender qué significa crear
riqueza y economía porque este mundo no
lo estamos acabando no los vamos a
acabar lo vamos a extinguir porque no
somos humanos que prevemos somos humanos
que reaccionamos ante la emergencia y
este tema climático es más grande que tú
y yo es más grande que tu fortuna así
que la pregunta es hasta dónde hasta
cuánto dinero cuánto vamos a pagar por
este error que tenemos hoy hemos creado
un 9 pez y con esto voy a cerrar nueve
peces que proponemos que deben ser la
nueva conversación sobre cómo diseñar
compañías como liderar países cómo
diseñar tu vida primer p es planeta no
podemos seguir creando dinero o riqueza
a consta de los recursos planetarios
segunda p personas necesitamos
focalizarnos a resolver los problemas
las experiencias de las personas y
también de la vida de este planeta
tercer p propósito no podemos crear
compañías que solamente estén destinadas
a crear dinero necesitamos crear
compañías que realmente tengan un alma
que funcionen que resuelvan que mejoren
que tengan un propósito increíble todos
los demás son desechables cuarta p que
empoderen que este nuevo poder no sea no
solamente sea entendido algo como a
tengo bastante poder en el mundo sino
esta capacidad de inspirar a otros de
empoderar a otros quinta p prospectiva
necesitamos pensar en futuro construir
nuestras decisiones del presente mirando
cómo va a impactar a los que no han
nacido y sobre todo cómo va a ser ese
mundo que vamos a heredar
siguiente p propuesta de valor ya no
solamente estamos diseñando productos y
servicios sino propuestas de valor que
impliquen una conversación más
sofisticada siguiente p google chrome
necesitamos entender qué significa el
diseño y no solamente el diseño como
algo gráfico sino el diseño como esta
capacidad de nosotros de intervenir
crear modificar y mejorar a través del
pensamiento creativo innovación y
pensamiento de diseño humano en este
planeta
plataforma y no solamente las
plataformas humanas que tocamos
físicamente sino también las plataformas
digitales como estamos entregando
nuestras experiencias
siguiente p performance evidentemente
todo esto tiene que ver con crear
riqueza estas 9 pues nosotros la vemos
como algo esencial una discusión
importante para cambiar al futuro de la
humanidad y repasó hable de la humanidad
interplanetaria y si definitivamente lo
vamos a hacer
hable de la humanidad extendida lo cual
fuerte explicó un poco de qué significa
este tiempo y yo también de la capacidad
robótica la capacidad genética y la
capacidad digital que vamos a tener y
estable de la humanidad artificial esta
humanidad que va a competir con un
algoritmo que es mucho más eficiente que
nosotros por lo tanto va a requerir que
saquemos lo mejor de nosotros en un que
se está extinguiendo que los recursos se
están evaporando y que el impacto
ambiental puede llevarnos a condenarnos
a una de las problemas más complejos de
la historia de la humanidad
cierro con esta frase toda la tecnología
que tenemos todos los canales de
comunicación que hemos creado tú y yo a
través de estas plataformas nos están
llevando a una pregunta importante si la
tecnología va a rebasar a la conciencia
humana cuidado entonces estamos en el
riesgo de una autodestrucción para
evitarlo necesitamos comprender ser
conscientes de las herramientas que
tenemos del futuro que necesitamos
diseñar de los pro de productos y
problemas del presente que necesitamos
modificar y todo hacerlo con un nivel de
conciencia como nunca antes lo habíamos
tenido cuando la tecnología rebasa a la
conciencia humana entonces viene la
autodestrucción sirva esto como una
advertencia para nuestra generación o
las generaciones que vienen no se dejen
rebasar por la tecnología y por la
ambición humana del poder y la economía
esto es un viaje de conciencia tenemos
un solo planeta y tenemos que cuidarlo
debemos de ser conscientes con la vida y
lo que significa ser humanos en este
planeta y en este sistema nos vemos en
el futuro ha sido un placer